Wisconsin University of Edinburgh and
the ADRC of Scotland will talk about
practical experience of making synthetic
dates at different
just a second I guess
[Applause]
that's fine you just need to start up
presentation there we go oh oh
lost it again
Oh
thank you very much I want to start by
using the logos on this slide to explain
how I got into this field of releasing
private data and synthetic data in
particular after I retired from my day
job over ten years ago where I used to
teach statistics at Edinburgh Napier
University I got a part-time job working
on the Scottish longitudinal study which
is based here if we look at this logo
there international records for Scotland
which is the agency that reports to the
Scottish government and has the same
role in Scotland as ONS does in England
and Wales it collects and administers
the census and all kinds of other
administrative data the next logo is the
Scottish longitudinal study itself it's
one of three UK longitudinal studies
that makes census data available to
researchers not just single individual
censuses but censuses linked over time
where people and families are trace
tracked from one census to the next and
also it's linked to many other data
sources including vital events births
deaths marriages NHS data including
hospital admissions series of hospital
admissions for individuals cancer
registrations Education data including
people excluded from school and
qualifications how many people
post-school qualifications people get so
it's got it's a very large collection of
linked databases when users apply to use
it they get their own individual extract
made for it and they have to then come
in to the sense - liddie well house in
Edinburgh which is where NRS is based
and work in the safe setting there with
a lot of restrictions no internet access
not even allowed to take any kind of
electronic devices in with them they
have to have everything checked as they
leave probably most of you are familiar
with this kind of
so after I've been working there for a
few years we really started reading
about synthetic data and particularly
some of the synthetic data products that
were being produced by the US Census
Bureau and so we applied in 2012 to get
some funding to make synthetic data sets
available from people who are using this
Kurdish language internal study to make
access easier and that's the logo for
the project to do that which is SILS
where you see the longitudinal people in
the scottish longitudinal study are
released replaced by their submit
synthetic versions no we couldn't do the
same kind of thing as has been done in
the u.s. to make since that what
particular synthetic data products
because no user ever gets the gets
access to the whole sls data they get
just their own little extract so we did
get our funding to do this but instead
of trying to make a synthetic Scottish
longitudinal study we decided to make
sorry haven't quite worked how to work
its net so that we would devise tools to
enable the staff in the longitudinal
study to make datasets for individuals
so bespoke pathetic data to do that we
develop the synth-pop package for our
which generates data that then be used
by the staff of the sls to make extracts
for users and after a lot of
administrative burdens going to
committees and trying to persuade them
we now have permission and we can supply
synthetic extracts to users and this
package is now available openly on cran
and you can look up our website to see
more about it and read the papers that
we've written about how we did it the
person who's done most of the
development work is better no walk here
who has done all the programming work
and her paper they are tells you a lot
about it we've also developed some new
methodology for synthetic data in the
process of doing that I should mention
that if you don't if you forget to put
the dot org dot uk' on the fifth part
website you'll get all kinds of
interesting things about electronic
music so be careful to remember to put
that bit in
synthetic data generated with oops sorry
synthetic that's the the program is open
but the synthetic data extracts are not
open they're supplied to trained and
trusted researchers have to sign forms
yet more forms and the data have to be
labeled as false data we've concentrated
on making the data useful and that's not
been trivial because there are many many
variables in the Scottish and the
longitudinal studies including trade
people's histories of being in hospital
that kind of thing and lots of
longitudinal linked data so the
synthetic data have no formal privacy
guarantees except that no records relate
to real or individuals so what I've
tried to do over the last month not for
a bit is to try to do some work to make
our synthetic data at least a small
portion of it see whether it might be
possible to make it differentially
private when we started developing the
synth-pop package we thought that the
idea of having differentially private
synthetic data was just impossible
because as soon as you have a synthetic
data set you can also get lots of
questions and you'll soon bust your
privacy budget but became aware recently
that there have been several papers
written that say that you can produce
differentially private synthetic data so
here's my efforts at trying to do this
it's very much work in progress and I
hope maybe I will learn more at this
workshop and be able to do a bit more in
the next month I wished I'd had longer
to spend on doing it so my outline of my
talk is I'm going to first of all talk a
little bit about synthetic data
generation with synth-pop source to show
the context and I'm going to look at
three possible methods of making
differentially private synthetic data
the first one I don't expect to work
very well it's very simple the second
one is a hybrid method of making the
sufficient statistics differentially
private
and the third one is this MWe M standing
for multiplicative weights exponential
mechanism which is pure differential
privacy and it looks promising
but we shall see and we'll try to
evaluate this using the synth-pop tool
for data utility that we've derived
usually to see if we had useful models
there and then finally I'll consider
briefly how synthetic data whether
differentially private or not perform on
simple statistical disclosure methods
which one can use for synthetic data
so how do we get synthetic data
we fit our model to an existing data set
we fit a model to an existing data set
including parameters for the signal and
the noise and then we can summarize the
results as a set of parameters or by
some other representation we think of
this as being all possible models being
a part of a set theta which could be a
parametric model or it could be
something a bit more complicated and we
then once we've got the fit to the data
which I've called theta phi here that's
a member of this set and we can create
one or more synthetic data sets by
sampling from this distribution we also
need the concept here that this met the
member of this set theta may originally
have been generated from some mechanism
up there in the world which we call the
correct generative model that it really
was generated by this model that we have
proposed from the dataset which of
course we'll never really know but what
we want to know over that we've chosen
the family for creating this synthetic
data to capture all the relations in
within the data that the user is likely
to be interested in and we can check
this from various utility measures with
known distributions which we've
developed as part of the package
first of all lack of fit measures which
are essentially Maha Novus distance
measures some differences in
coefficients you get from fitting a
model to the original data or the
synthetic data and you can test that and
then a series of measures based on the
PM se which stands for predictor of mean
square error which you get by putting
the synthetic data and the original data
together and attempting to discriminate
between the two by looking to see
whether you can find an adequate
discriminator and I think Joshua is
going to be talking a bit more about
that measure tomorrow in his talk it
turns out that for tabular data the
standard PM SC model can be shown to be
identical to a particular chi-squared
test or the difference between the
original and the synthesis
but more importantly when we practically
produce synthetic data we tend not to
use these measures as much as we use
simple graphical tools for just
comparing them it's much easier to do
that that's all simple I'm a simple
person I'll show an example shortly so
the models we use for a data synthesize
since these are mostly commonly built up
from conditional models synth-pop offers
14 choices for each conditional model
and the predictors for each conditional
model can be selected the order can be
changed so you can do lots of
complicated things but most people
actually just use the default now model
which i think is - most programs that
anybody ever uses the default is that
you do them in the order you happen to
have written them in in the data set and
you'd use used it to find each
conditional model as a cart model
classification and regression trees and
mostly that works pretty well but last
year I thought it might be a good idea
to try and build in some models base for
a sets of categorical data because a lot
of our category our data are categorical
that we could use - by specifying log
linear models that we can test on the
data and I noticed when I was doing this
that these map very conveniently on the
work - the work on making counting
queries for differential privacy so
that's what I'm going to try and look at
today and I'm going to try to develop
different methods of generating
categorical synthetic data
I'm going to use two datasets to compare
the methods the two datasets are first
of all a survey data about the quality
of life in Poland in 2011 which is
available as part of the synth-pop
package I've selected seven variables
from it the other dataset that's a lot
smaller than the usual data that we have
to synthesize in the sls unit so in
order to get a larger dataset I went to
the ICM project held in university
university of s exeter and in england
which makes historic census data
available for researchers I picked out
some data from the 1911 census of
Scotland selecting a set of parishes
that include the city of Edinburgh so
that's a bit more like the data that we
usually use the survey data has 5000
records the ICM data has 75,000 records
again I selected seven variables from
that to synthesize and then to try to
synthesize eventually privately so in
each case I'm going to show you briefly
how we did the synthesis linear models
we used iterative proportional fitting
first of all we analyze the data find a
suitable log linear model and then
represented the data as a table the
seven way table because we've got seven
variables and to find them me the
margins that would be constrained by the
model we had chosen and then fitted the
model by iterative proportional fitting
starting with a uniform distribution as
you usually do updating it from the
chosen American its margins is most
people here probably familiar with this
method it's slow but reliable the output
provides a probability for each cell in
the table that's compatible with the
margins so we generate synthetic data
from a multinomial sample across these
probabilities
sometimes and if we if we were to do
that simply with zeros in ourselves we
would retain these zeros so we add a
small quantity to each sell unless we
think there is sell that could never
exist a structural zero and we generate
synthetic data from a multinomial based
on these probabilities so it's very
straightforward just to say a little bit
more about the properties of the two
data sets very different number of
Records because they have the same
number or similar number of variables
with similar numbers of categories they
each form a table which have roughly the
same number of cells around to twelve
thousand in each case the largest cells
however are very different you see in
the survey data they're around largest
one is 54 whereas in the ICM data are
much larger but in both cases the
percentage of 0 cells is similar to
about 83 percent so to do this in
synth-pop it's very easy you just need
one line this is the line that we used
for the survey data where you fitted
log-linear models we found that here we
had evidence that all second-order
interactions were important plus there's
only really one third order in
interaction that passed the been on for
a rebound but there were two others that
looked as if they might be getting close
so for synthesis we included three third
order interactions the ICM data there
was evidence that well almost all the
third order interactions were important
so we synthesized that with all third
order interactions whereas the survey
data was synthesized here with just the
two interactions plus the extra ones
that we've added in here so how did the
results look
this is from the survey data each of the
seven variables we look at the dark the
observed data the right the synthetic
data is just shown as proportions and I
think you would agree these match pretty
well numbers above each of the
histograms if the ratio to the degrees
of freedom for the tabular utility
measure for comparing the two tables and
you can see that as expected
they're also somewhere around one which
we know because in fact this model is
compatible with the model that we've
used to synthesize now similarly if we
move on to looking at an analysis from
this data here we're predicting not
smoking in the survey and you can see if
you're a female you're more likely to be
a nonsmoker this is a forest plot which
shows the odds ratios and that's the
value of one in the middle that we
expressed it here as said values and you
can see that also education this one
here these are secondary education makes
you more likely to be a nonsmoker
they're in a rural area you're more
likely to be a nonsmoker and if you're
older here we've got overlap in the
confidence intervals of 82 percent which
is quite reasonable and the test of lack
of fit comes out fine again because what
we would expect here so
for the ICM data we also got good
agreement as we would expect in this
case instead of looking at fitting a
model I've looked at a three-way
relationship between the measure of home
occupancy which is persons per room and
whether the family has children and
whether the head of the household is an
employer I've called it a boss here or
an employee now if we look at the data
here look at this lowest one these are
people that are living at more than four
people per room now you can see there's
quite a big difference between these
groups if you're an employee with
children a lot of the families will be
living with more than four people in
their room whereas the other extreme if
you're an employer with no children it's
quite likely that you might have more
rooms than you have people which is
quite unusual in these days you just put
in a couple of pictures of Edinburgh at
that time or in fact a bit earlier that
picture there shows the overcrowding in
the old town which is where these people
would be more likely to live whereas the
ones at the top the red ones there would
be more likely to live in the spacious
newly built areas of Edinburgh a new
town that where there would be more
rooms than there were people so that's
to give you an idea of what the data
synthesis would like without making it
differentially private
so four days four differentially private
synthesis well each of the three methods
I mentioned I've taken four choices of
epsilon 5 which I think is reasonable
one which not as good as the point five
two could be better
five I think is pretty useless because
it gives you a hundred and fifty fold
ratio which is really not much of a
privacy guarantee so moving on to what
is method one this was very simple make
a seven-way table of the counts remember
around 12000 say upsells ad Laplace
noise defined by epsilon to each cell
constrain the synthetic counts to be
nonzero and to be integers with a total
equal to the original sample size
because the important thing about our
SLS synthetic data is that we want it to
look plausible we want the users to
believe that it looks like the real data
so that their programs will work in the
same way on it as they would on the real
data no it's not trivial to do that even
one long sample because obviously we
need to round the answers
so once we've added the Laplace toys we
get quite a lot of negative values so
what I've done to make it at least work
is to set the negative values to zero to
rescale the whole thing up to the sample
size and to round to the nearest integer
that now doesn't sound sum up to n so
you've got to do a further adjustment to
make your sample size come out right and
that I did by getting the count for the
largest cell and subtracting it from
some of the rest
so then adds up to the sample size for
naturally asks me I did try the idea of
using discrete distribution but actually
was even worse because I got too many
zeroes
maybe that would try be a possibility so
what happens when we look at these data
first of all looking at the survey data
going to the same distribution now four
levels of epsilon here and these are the
ratios of the tabular utility measure
the ratios to the expectation for each
of these univariate tables epsilon of
0.5 you can see things are not looking
very good these histograms are not
matching at the top it was slightly
better for some variables than others
but I think you would agree this is not
good when you take Epps on up to 0.5
it looks ok the ones in between us you
expect our intermediate no so you did
the love in your model and you got these
sort of predictions or the piece and
then you multiply the end to get a count
and then each one of those counts you
added Nordstrom yeah no no I added noise
to the raw data to all the interior
cells of the 70 because you're feeling a
next one that's the next one no this was
this was really just an experiment that
I didn't expect to work yes
so I guess two things so first of all
the fact that it did work for epsilon
equals five suggests that there's
something it's perhaps not as portable
as I would have expected I'll tell you
later why it's because you're really by
doing that you've hardly changed at all
further in the talk again what is the
number what are the numbers that are
plotted in this tape but not plotted but
in the table what are the you would send
there were ratios of some kind for each
this time I'm just adding Laplace noise
to the raw data that's all I'm doing I'm
thinking that will be my synthetic data
set I'm not doing any of the modeling
stuff at all sorry I should have made
that clear yeah for each case you take
the original data and the synthetic data
and you calculate a chi-squared value
it's not an ordinary chi-squared because
you have to allow the possibility for
the bottom line to be you replace the
usual expected value in the bottom with
the average of the expertly observed and
the expected it's a distant measure
that's right and if you were doing
synthesis as synth-pop does then it
would give you ratios averaging at one
here we're not adding log in the raw
data you get zero but here what you're
really doing I realized after I'd done
it is that you're looking at the ratio
between your Laplace noise and plus or
error because if you were doing the
ordinary synthesis you would be
effectively looking at the fossil error
it's not Sara if you were to here you've
got Laplace error of different sizes
just for calibration if you were to take
a subsample of half of the data which
you expect numbers in on the order of 0
1 and all those yes yes yes now it
always ain't correct like if you knew
the correct other distribution and
expectation you'd expect these numbers
make 1 mm okay yes thank you that's that
univariate tables so I understand how
when you're adding noise to all the
different cells you're gonna get a ton
of variance around like what you know
some are gonna be way too low so I'm
gonna be way too high I guess I'm not
seeing the intuition so for instance I'm
just maybe I'm misinterpreting this in
the histogram on the top like for the
second one in from the right that's
trust they're like three different
values I guess for how much and it seems
like the marginal distribution is way
off and I guess I would have intuitively
expected that if you're adding iid noise
to all these different cells sure like
each individual cell is gonna be all off
but should they should be the same a lot
of variance and I guess you're right
which is that you're doing a lot of
rounding and fixing and that's probably
making things worse trust us in a market
these are this was just done by the very
simple-minded business of attaching
noise to every single cell in the table
let's trust one of the variable spanning
this table size is the same but because
you've got different proportions of
zeros it won't necessarily come out the
same for the individual variables
this seems like to be a case where
actually if you haven't done the
rounding and you just publish the
negative values you might actually get a
much much more precise it's definitely
definitely by our users with knots of
like negative sorry I've got a lot more
stuff to do so I must be quick right so
in fact the two-way relationships don't
look so good you can see that with
absolute 5 and here the confidence
interval overlap is minus 2 percent I'm
going up to 78% what's the next one of
0.5 you get more or less the right
answer but as also show shortly that's
because you've really added very little
either error presumably also these you
can like get back to exactly where you
should be you do Roy's noise correction
after rounding I don't know that's a
problem with the rounding out the
negative to zero in many cases it turned
out adapter choice neither more than the
specific differentiate or that's true
yeah yeah I'm sure that's true so just
moving on now the larger data set the
ratios which I'll skip over quickly you
don't look very different but these now
are the two absolute point five and
point one the proportions actually don't
look too bad and the reasons they don't
look too bad is that the signal in the
data here is much greater than the noise
that we're adding and similarly if we
look at four different versions of that
three-way table as I showed you before
for the different Epsilon's even with an
epsilon of 0.5 we're really not doing
too badly so just to summarize this
method works well provided the signal in
the data is bigger than the scale of the
noise that's added it's not true from
the survey data except for completely
useless excellence from the Census
so you get to adjust that epsilon for
the fact that it was a sampling it might
not have been as useless as you think
tell me later so going on to the second
method
oh sorry
this is the one that I've referred to
before this time we add noise to the
marginals and of course if we got em
marginals we have to add noise that is
divided but has increased by dividing
epsilon by M so we had have to add
epsilon star rather than that now we
have different kinds of constraints we
don't need to worry about them being
whole numbers but all the margins must
be greater than zero and they must be
compatible then once we've got these
margins which are not whole numbers we
use iterative proportional fitting to
get the self probabilities corresponding
to margins we generate synthetic data
from a multinomial sample of size n for
these probabilities it's very fiddly to
actually get the to get the margins to
match but it's possible and that gives
for method to good utility here also
good utility for
for those models and the same was true
of the ICM data so this method works
much better it seems to work well
writing code to get the marginals to
match is tricky and perhaps this method
could be adapted to cart type models
because I know there are some papers
that allow you to do this I haven't read
them yet but since this seems to work I
thought that's the next stage that I
might try no the third method is the
multiplication of weights exponential
method probably most people in this room
know how that works so well be speedy
you start with the original table you
decide on a set of queries you
initialize the table with a uniform
distribution you then have to choose
your epsilon and your T before you do
the analysis so you can't let it run
forever like the initial the pictures
with proportional fitting you have to
decide what your T is for each query you
select you you start the procedure by
choosing a query based on the difference
between the noisy data and your data
your current version of your data you
get a score and you select a quick query
with this probability and then you
update your tabular data and you can
speed this up a lot because this bit
here where you've added noise to your
data you can use that same version again
without using the data once more so
every time you do it
you can get all the previous queries run
after T iterations you then have some
numbers which you you can decide that's
good enough and adjust the rounding
threshold you can you then need to round
them and you can adjust the rounding
threshold for zeros to correctly to get
the correct
n so the big question there is how you
actually choose your T
so what I did was to look and this is
for the ICM data with 35 3 bein
interactions looked at the plot of what
was happening to the different than l1
norm of the difference between the
original table and the synthetic table
and you see it seems to flatten out
around 50 it slightly differently for
the different epsilon values so that
suggests a T of 50 and so that was what
I used for the ICM data for the survey
data things did not work nearly so well
and I still don't quite know what's
wrong
sometimes things were very irregular I
had to use a lower T to get the thing to
work at all here at T of 25 and I'm
still not convinced that this stuff is
remotely correct
there's only 35 threeway yeah how does
that relate to what your void cells
before we're twelve to twelve thousand
well it's just the three we interactions
between your seven variables and twelve
thousand of all whole interactions
interaction so for the ICM data the
one-way marginals for both cases seem to
work quite well and similarly for the
census data that all looked fine the
survey data the fitted values it was
completely unsatisfactory even for Epson
of five so maybe
so that'd three perhaps looks promising
but it needs more work my code needs
checking I don't know how to choose T so
perhaps some of you people have
developed these methods here could help
me to improve it so just finally I want
to talk briefly about a disclosure
method for a synthetic data
imagine you've got an eye a naive
intruder who finds the synthetic data
this is a big concern for the Census
Bureau because if somebody leaves
synthetic data lying around on a train
and leaves their laptop behind that
might well be thought to be the real
thing and the bureau might lose their
reputation so if you know someone who's
in this population you know certain key
variables and try to identify them you
find them and try to find some other
individual about something else about
them so an example of attribute
disclosure but it's compounded by the
fact that for synthetic data you are
sometimes going to be wrong so using a
measure called the correct relative
attribution probability to find a set of
key variables look at your attribute and
tabulate the attributes by all
combinations of the key in the synthetic
data and these red lines are ones where
for example with that choice you would
find out this person is a single person
similarly here but of course that that
proportion of your records which would
be disclosed of is just the proportion
of those over the whole data set but
then you have to also reckon that some
of these will be wrong so you multiply
it by the proportion correct so for
example if I try to predict certain
features you know in the u.s. race by
neighborhood I could do that very very
well in many cases regardless of whether
or not you know a person was in the
database to begin with or anything like
that so I wondered is there something
what's what's the kind of baseline
against which it's just the proportion
if this is just a very simple measure
it's the proportion of records that
you'd be able to identify and you can
run it against all the variables in your
data set and see which one is the most
sensitive
identify using its it's like a
prediction it's an attribute disclosure
what you want to know is can you find
out the marital status of this person
from this he derived from these other
variables very simple nearly finished
I'm sorry I'm a few minutes late so
let's see what happens with these rather
in these different measures what are our
crap measure I've got two variables here
one of which is trust for the survey
data and in each case I chose four or
five other variables to be the key you
can see you that with the original data
for the since census date I've chosen a
variable which has a two percent
sensitivity whereas for the ICM it's
worse that's for employment status and
that's because there is a small category
of pauper in there which there aren't
very many people and eight percent of
the records there will be the non
private no non differentially private
synthetic data only gains in crap index
from the fact that you're sometimes
going to be wrong it doesn't do very
well model one I'm pleased to say does
actually four except for the very
highest excellence give you zero crap
measures because you've actually got rid
of all these sensitive cells so I
thought that was very encouraging but of
course these top ones are really not
very helpful whereas when you add large
amounts of noise and you examine the
data you've not added enough noise to
get them to move any distance from the
real data so they more or less look like
the original thing when you do that
so that's not much good now model 2 and
model 3 are rather odd because the
certainly in all cases we've got
remember that was 8% going down to
ranges between 1 and 2% that one haven't
quite finished whereas for the 2% again
they're all lower but they don't seem to
value with the excellence which is all
other puzzling and perhaps some of you
can help me to understand why we've got
these draw the strange results so finish
with a few final thoughts
certainly I need to do more work in this
if it's going to be any use perhaps
there are other different methods that
might work better
I think model 2 is the way to go forward
if at all but it needs a correct
generative model and that's surely going
to be the same be true also of other
data dependence differential private
methods like the MWA m1 prioritize
queries so knowing what queries to use
is going to be difficult it's
encouraging that differential privacy
does lead to lower disclosure control in
this rather simple measure but some of
the results are still puzzling so I'd
like to finally finish by thanking you
for inviting me here and letting me have
a go at it I find some of the literature
in this field very difficult to read but
those papers in particular but the ones
that I found helpful paper by Ian
Schmidt in the statistical Journal of
the iOS in 2016 helped me to understand
the endo uem method the report of the
census technical report by John about
and spout should also look to the mwm
method and had a nice algorithm that was
very helpful but the version in the
economics journal now uses a different
method and I haven't read it yet so
maybe that would be good of course I
have to mention the mwm paper by Hart
Liggett and McSherry
paper in statistical science by [ __ ]
and other people was extremely helpful
and the other paper I find extremely
helpful is the paper by hare tower using
this DP bench which uses real data so
it's really nice to see some of
this differentially private stuff being
used on real data in our lunch buy will
allow one reached fifty questions but we
can take it over okay so then we'll
think again
[Applause]